hi i'm jake cohen author of the cookbook
jewish and this is 51st plates
drew you have to try german sabzi with
tariq this persian combo
it's absolutely incredible it was truly
like a ratatouille moment for me
when i met my husband alex we started
dating very early on like i got requests
to start making some of his childhood
favorites and these are two of them and
they're truly magical gourmet sabzi is
the stew of beef with kidney beans tons
of chopped herbs and dried lime so it's
tangy and rich and herbaceous and then
tajik is a crispy persian rice
it's like crispy carbs are always the
best and this is like might be the best
version of it
perfume the saffron i mean this is like
this is your childhood so i mean it's so
funny because like growing up you know
you think of like classic american
comfort food it's like your friends are
eating hamburgers and meatloaf and like
for me my my classic comfort food was
gourmet savvy it's common in persian
households and of course persian jewish
households you know of course like you
had to learn how to make it for me um
there was no there was no option and you
could find my mother-in-law's recipe for
both in jewish so
definitely drew should not only try it
but she should cook it as well
[Music]
you